another heartbreaking decision for the
hillsborough families
a last chance at securing further
criminal convictions slipped away today
when the judge in this latest trial
ruled there was no case to be heard
what a very sad day today is for the
justice system of this country
32 years the families have been fighting
to get to the truth and accountability
for 96 innocent victims who lost their
lives at hillsborough
two former police officers and a
solicitor had been on trial for
perverting the course of justice
they had denied accusations that they
changed police statements to minimize
blame on south yorkshire police
following the disaster at the fa cup
semi-final in 1989
in which 96 liverpool fans died
former shadow home secretary andy
burnham said echoes of hillsborough run
through victims of
other tragedies as he called for changes
to the law
how much of the families given to this
fight
it has to be about changing the way
things are
if they're going to level up this
country you need to level up ordinary
citizens when they walk into a courtroom
against the authorities of this country
at the moment it's a massive
mismatch today's decision means that
even though a previous inquest had ruled
that the 96
were unlawfully killed only one person
has ever been held to account
and that was for a single safety offence
after a trial in 2019
and despite the trial collapsing the
crown prosecution service defended the
decision to prosecute
saying the cps was right to bring this
case and for a court to hear the
evidence of what happened in the
aftermath of the hillsborough disaster
mary and brenda both lost their sons in
the tragedy
i don't think we'll ever have closure
and for what we've been through and
by today as well we can't appeal on that
decision
so for me there's no closure
and we'll still be going up and putting
flowers on the grave and it just brings
all the horrible memories that you've
been trying to forget forgotten it was
that many years
and it brings everything back to the
surface and you just feel
so angry both women say the truth of
what happened that day is clear
even if justice is harder to achieve
sadia chowdhury sky news in liverpool